we have this story from the
post-millennial New York City jury found
Douglas Mackey guilty in first ever meme
trial after making memes that disparaged
Hillary Clinton in the 2016 election I
have the tweet it was this uh that would
be my first party man that guy that was
Ricky Vaughn right well but he's one of
the great like the original yeah like
sort of Twitter accounts like Maga
accounts I mean think about we live in a
country right now it's the United States
of America where they want to put a guy
for a meme in jail for 10 years
not one they're gonna
Yeah well yeah yeah you're right they've
already lost the trial theoretic like
like that would be my first pardon
because but it's it's safe level you
can't pardon him like that's think of
the things that think of the thing oh
you're right I guess but think of the
things that though degenerate left puts
out there and not a consequence no one
ever goes after they don't even get fact
checked I mean I look at some of the
stuff they say about me I'm like well
these are demonstrably false and they're
like yeah wow we can't we can't look at
that let's go but you fact check me when
I say this is my opinion and you you
come up with some sort of arbitrary way
to say well that's fact I'm like I'm not
allowed to have an opinion well so we
also have this tweet from Christina Wong
where on uh November uh November 8th
2016 she did almost the exact same thing
tweeting out for Trump supporters to
text in their vote she didn't include a
number but she even included super
Wednesday a fake day for voting and
she's not been charged so I see this
story as a perfect example of
partnership that's how it works there's
not there's no equal justice under our
law anymore we have a two-tiered system
okay whether it's Christina Wong versus
the Ricky Vaughn whether it's Hunter
Biden versus me you know it can't be
more apparent and again it's not like
it's just anomalous they only go one way
politically only one way politically
there's not even I can't even come up
with examples of the left on this and
again whether that's censorship whether
that's actual prosecution uh the list
goes on and on it's it's so stacked did
you we have to understand that and we
have to all be engaged in that because
otherwise it's over did you know that
the Marshall's outside of the uh Supreme
Court Justices homes were ordered not to
arrest the protesters unless absolutely
necessary despite the fact the protests
are actually illegal
yeah and and if we did that to Ruth
Bader Ginsburg before she passed they'd
have all been in there with the January
6th prisoners
how many people were arrested Tim uh you
know in the summer of love you know in
the 2020 you know billions and billions
of dollars of damaged people murdered
David Dorne and others uh buildings
burnt to the ground arson yeah you can
you can loot a Gucci store and you know
what it works because you know it's in
the name of social justice you ready for
this one you ready for this one how many
were arrested this one actually this
this is important
there were 19 plus deaths and 14 000
arrests now it may sound like well then
there these people are being held
accountable right you mean if somebody
were let go right away not only were
most of them probably let go but don't
you think 14
000 plus arrests over a period of two
weeks should be the major story of the
past few years like yeah 14
000 people were arrested
they were mostly peaceful oh right right
two billion dollars I was watching a
reporter say that live because I was
like man this is crazy I don't want he
goes it's mostly peaceful I go dude
there's a building burning in the
background and like three seconds later
the reporter got hit in the head with
like a brick yeah I'm like but but they
went to like don't believe you're a
lying eyes you can see it it's happening
in real time yeah but to your point
we're trying to do to Kyle Rittenhouse
like oh God lunacy well to your point
about the folks you know getting
arrested and being let go right away I
mean there's a great deal of people that
that fall into that bucket but like just
a total prosecution number of those
people are like 50 60 January 6th
defendants in Washington DC there's a 99
conviction rate 99 of course because
because you can't there's there's you
can't find an impartial jury in
Washington DC they know that it's what
they're doing with Trump in New York
you're not gonna find you know people in
a a jury that aren't going to convict
Trump yeah you don't have people that
believe uh you know that he's got to
write a fair trial they're fine saying
ah you know we're they're really for
democracy when they can make up some
sort of sound bite against it but if
they can use it to weaponize against
someone else who doesn't share their
exact opinion we've seen this this is
how the left has functioned as they've
sort of devolved into you know
full-blown you know stalinist you know
type mentalities uh you know look at
what they've done to like Martina
Navratilova right uh oh yeah incredible
tennis player one of the leaders of the
you know the gay and lesbian movement
she was preaching for that movement and
fighting for that movement 30 years
before it became All the Rage way before
it was cool but then when she came out a
couple years ago and was like well I
don't think men should be like competing
against women in sports like I was one
of the elite women athletes of all time
and like the men would have destroyed me
they canceled her 30 years of activism
just for having a different opinion
and complete surrender we again we've I
hit it earlier in the talk but like uh
you know we saw that this weekend you
know it it we really should be you know
praying for the trans Community because
they're at risk I'm like what
we're getting a minerals night I'm like
but where like I haven't I haven't heard
anything what are you talking about like
I'm committing genocide by saying I
don't believe a three-year-old uh it
should be given puberty blockers
enforced uh into something by a teacher
without parent parents being involved
and I don't think I think they should
have liability to the doctors when that
kid turns of legal age the recidivism
rate is like 94 if that kid turns of age
and is not happy anymore they should be
able to sue the teacher I got the doctor
their parents anyone else who is
involved in this decision-making process
because that kid couldn't buy a pack of
cigarettes for 15 years but we're gonna
give them
life-altering body altering meds and
drugs and hormones and that like to be
against that makes makes me you know a
committer of Genesis it's stupid I want
to ask you two more questions one one uh
one of them will be a bit simpler but
the first one is we're getting a lot of
people asking about your views on Julian
Assange and whether or not he should be
pardoned
yeah you know that's it's a really
interesting question uh Assange uh
listen I I years ago when it first
started happening I would have said no
now I'm like oh my God like he's he was
on this stuff you know again years ago I
was like all right you know him um the
other guy who gave up the military
secrets with uh
Edward Snowden
Snowden yeah yeah you know I would have
been like I would have taken the no no
no
a hundred percent
a hundred percent you got to let those
guys out because they actually caught us
doing all the things we said we weren't
gonna do wow they caught us in the lie
and like it's out there like
and now I've seen what what's actually
going on again my world view uh the
America I believed or wanted to believe
existed like that doesn't exist anymore
guys it and every day that's further and
further gone we just are being more and
more awakened to the reality of the
situation it's not that it's getting
worse it's probably been really bad for
a long period of time we just now know
it and we're seeing it with our own eyes
I don't think so yeah I don't think that
was it that's an easy question to answer
but there were a lot of people I think
my mind has my mind has changed on that
a lot when even when we first got into
politics I'd have been like no that's a
bad thing we can't have that but I'm
like now everybody's cheering now that
they're like yeah yeah so you're right
we got I got one more question though
because I we're going to jump over to
this Andrew Tate story but while we have
you uh the the next question that
everyone seems to be asking is how how
and when can we get your dad on the show
and you I mean have you actually come in
the studio to be honest
honestly if I can do anything to avoid
going into DC I usually will but but uh
I'll take it up there and coming there
I'll I'll talk to him about that and by
the way another example right like and
if someone you know I I've hung out with
I've you know going back and forth like
he feels like he's been in jail like I
don't even know they haven't even told
us what he's done he didn't charge he's
not charged with anything
on his behalf it's crazy I mean it's an
example of what this country could
become if we let go of our constitution
well but it but it sort of has right
like like he was when I spoke to him you
know last I was like hey man come on you
know if you come to the states I'm not
going to the states they'll put me in
jail I'm like States will you know I
don't think like legitimately I don't
think that oh sorry to interrupt you
there oh no no no worries um I don't
think that it's that it's bad that it's
really I mean it is obviously it's not
that it's getting worse it's that we're
seeing how bad it is and we have an
opportunity to make it better like it's
been bad for a long time we're just like
every day we're like oh here's another
example of how bad it is uh you know a
guy like that he's held without whatever
I don't know like if you're doing what
he's doing it's and it's hard right it's
hard for me like the Flynn example I
used earlier like well like well if he's
trafficking women like well maybe I
gotta stay silent maybe I gotta you know
you can't you can't come out against
that it's like yo I'm a very strong
believer that that's terrible and
but that's what they do but then you
know nothing happens they can put you
away for six months like well why are
they going after him to begin with oh
because he's actually influencing a lot
of young males uh talking about you know
masculinity being okay and not not
necessarily the four-letter word that
it's made out to be oh God forbid you
have you know high tea you know you're
not a soy uh kid walking around with it
like I don't know like it seems odd it
seems that anyone that speaks out
against that system even a little bit uh
or or would encourage a large group of
people to not just buy into it you know
they're just singled out and and
isolated and effectively taken out and
again if he did something that's
terrible I don't I don't condone it but
man it seems like you couldn't put
someone in jail for a few months not
show anything and expect us to believe
it's actually real right like we should
be cynical based on virtually everything
we've seen uh in the world for the last
six years and you know maybe that's the
greatest thing the greatest Legacy of
Trump would be that he actually the
Trump derangement syndrome that ensued
uh
uh showed us all of these things that we
probably would not have seen otherwise
we're going to jump over to covering
that story but uh I gotta say dude
seriously thank you so much for coming
on as long as you did I thought we were
going to get you for a couple minutes we
had you on for like it's been almost
like an hour so bro uh thanks for
hanging out all right sorry to cut in on
Alexa but you know you're still my
Thunderman I'm trying to get famous over
here yeah hey guys the reality like I
said I it'd be easy to shut up and be a
real estate guy in New York you know we
got plenty of good assets like like I
actually I believe this stuff like it it
means something to me I like I you know
I don't do it lightly it's not a it's
not an act or stick like we got to do
something about it and uh you know I
I've I've had I guess a blessing of
having my eyes open to what's really
going on and I got to make sure that
other people see that thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time